well one organization here in the valley
is looking for mothers in need
help of southern nevada's diaper bank
have resources for pre and post birth
phan coleman is live this morning with
more on what they're offering hey bianca
you know how expensive diapers can be
and so that's why help of southern
nevada has set up a
diaper bank here in the on off of lake
mead and so you can see
all the various things that they have
here available for
those families and i'm joined here by
abby quinn with help of southern nevada
good morning thanks for joining us so
tell us more about
this offering for those mothers who are
expecting a new bundle of joy
absolutely this is our presence in north
las vegas it's definitely an underserved
area and so we're here this is the
second location we have we do have
another diaper bank on monday at our
east flamingo road so here we assist
parents with diapers and wipes
formula bottles the different items that
they need
so that they don't have to worry about
these things when they bring home baby
yeah and again some pregnancies are
planned some are not and i know we're
probably going to be expecting lots of
quarantine babies so this is probably
just a huge relief for so many that you
serve
absolutely we don't want our clients to
have to decide uh
if they're going to feed their baby or
if they're going to die for them and
that's a basic need for a baby to be
changed the health of the baby if the
parent is working
in order to bring your child to daycare
you have to provide them with diapers
so the need is definitely great we have
seen where we used to be a supplemental
service we're definitely now a place
that people are coming because they need
assistance throughout the entire month
wow and then also it's not just a good
the diapers that you have and the
resources that you have in the items
you also do some education and training
definitely we have to make sure that
we're wrapping services around our
clients so we have a car seat safety
training
in which a client can get a new car seat
we also have safe sleep certification
teach you how to sleep
you know properly put your baby down and
we offer a pack and play
and any services that we might not
provide we are able we collaborate with
different organizations in the community
and help
that client get what they need well and
i know probably there's some folks at
home their ears perked up when they
heard that needing a pack and play
and a car seat for free resources if you
need them if you're in help so
how can people get connected they have
to make an appointment right absolutely
so we want you to reach out to diapers
at help sonv.org if you can't remember
that
info help sonvu.org will get you to the
same place
all right perfect so again we're going
to have all this information on our
website i've tweeted it out if you need
that help
if you know a mother in need if you
again i have a family member that has
got to be expecting a baby soon or has a
young toddler or a baby
infant zero to three right zero to three
is the age that they're helping with
we can get you connected and get these
resources into your home i'm gonna send
it back to you guys in the studio
wonderful service thank you so much for
letting us know about that bianca